>> Sean: DEMOCRATS ARE EMBROILED
IN YET ANOTHER ANTI-SEMITISM
SCANDAL AFTER CONGRESSWOMAN
TALIB TALKED ABOUT, QUOTE,ING
THE CALMING FEELING SHE GETS
WHEN THINKING ABOUT THE
HOLOCAUST, ABOUT HOW
PALESTINIANS HELPED CREATE A
SAFE HAVEN FOR JEWS AFTER THE
HOLOCAUST.
A CALMING EFFECT?
OKAY.
THIS IS SICK BEYOND MEASURE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE'S A CALMING FEELING I
ALWAYS TELL FOLKS WHEN I THINK
OF THE HOLOCAUST, THE TRAGEDY OF
THE HOLOCAUST, THE FACT IT WAS
MY ANCESTORS, PALESTINIANS, WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES AND HUMAN
DIGNITY.
ALL OF IT WAS IN THE NAME OF
TRYING TO CREATE A SAVE HAVEN
FOR JEWS.
>> Sean: HERE'S REACTION TO
DISCUSS THE DEMOCRATS'
ANTI-SEMITISM SCANDAL THAT KEEPS
GROWING.
ALSO TONIGHT'S BREAKING NEWS ON
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR
ASSIGNING A FEDERAL PROSECUTOR
TO LOOK INTO THE ORIGINS OF THE
RUSSIA PROBES, TEXAS SENATOR TED
CRUZ.
FIRST OMAR'S COMMENTS.
THEN MULTIPLE TALIB'S COMMENTS.
AND THEN WE'VE GOT, BELIEVE IT
OR NOT, WHICH SHOCKED ME, A MOM
BROUGHT IN BY NANCY PELOSI, WHO
IN 2017 POSTED A IMAGE ON SOCIAL
MEDIA SUPPORTING THE MUSLIM
BROTHERHOOD.
IN 2014, ACTUALLY POSTED, QUOTE,
GOD WILLING ON THIS BLESSED
NIGHT AS THE THIRD EMPTY FADDA
BEGINS, THE END OF ZIONISM IS
HERE, MAY ALLAH HELP US OVER
COME.
THAT'S NANCY PELOSI, THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE, THAT INVITED THIS
RADICAL.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> WELL, IT'S UNFORTUNATELY A
GROWING PROBLEM.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS A WHOLE
IS GALLOPING TO THE LEFT.
ONE OF THE COMPONENTS OF THAT IS
THE EXTREME LEFT HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF ANTI-SEMITISM,
ANTI-ISRAEL HATRED.
WE'RE SEEING IT WITH THIS
FRESHMAN TRIO, THESE THREE
FRESHMAN HOUSE MEMBERS WHO KEEP
EXPRESSING ANTI-ISRAEL,
ANTI-SEMITIC COMMENTS ABOUT THE
HOLOCAUST, WHICH ARE HORRIFYING,
OR ATTACKING ISRAEL, SAYING IT'S
ALL ABOUT THE BENJAMINS.
IT'S REPEATING ANTI-SEMITIC
ATTACKS.
IT WOULD BE ONE THING IF IT'S A
COUPLE OF FRINGE RADICALS IN
THEIR PARTY, BUT AT LEAST IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS A WHOLE, THE
LEADERSHIP AS A WHOLE, IS
UNWILLING TO DISTANCE THEMSELVES
FROM THESE RADICALS, FROM THESE
EXTREME AND REALLY HARMFUL
SENTIMENTS.
>> Sean: FOR NANCY PELOSI TO
INVITE THAT PERSON IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
THE BREAKING NEWS, THE U.S.
ATTORNEY GENERAL ASSIGNING
MR. DURHAM, A FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR.
HE WILL LOOK INTO THE BEGINNINGS
OF ALL OF, THIS THE FBI'S TIES,
ETC., ETC., IN THIS CASE.
ALSO INSPECTOR GENERAL HOROWITZ,
JOHN UBER, HIS REPORT, THE
DEEPER INVESTIGATION INTO BOTH
THE RIG ELECTION OF HILLARY, OR
RIGGED INVESTIGATION OF HILLARY,
THE FISA ABUSE, AND THE ABUSE OF
POWER THAT HAPPENED THEREAFTER,
NEVER MIND THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY SURVEILLING UNMASKING
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND LEAKING
RAW INTELLIGENCE.
>> IT'S A GOOD DEVELOPMENT THE
U.S. ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS ASSIG
ASSIGNED THIS INVESTIGATION, THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION SURVEILLING
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
IT IS A VERY DANGEROUS THING
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT OR THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY IS USED
AS A POLITICAL WEAPON, USED TO
TARGET YOUR POLITICAL
ADVERSARIES.
AS I TRAVEL TEXAS, I HEAR FROM
TEXANS ALL OVER THE STATE, HOW
COME THERE'S NO ACCOUNTABILITY?
HOW COME THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WAS ABLE TO
WEAPONIZE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE?
WE NEED TO INVESTIGATE HOW
POLITICIZED IT WAS, AND IN
PARTICULAR WHAT WERE THE ROLES
OF THE LIT APPOINTEES?
WHO SIGNED OFF ON IT?
WAS IT LORETTA LYNCH?
WAS IT JOHN BRENNAN?
WAS IT JOE BIDEN?
WAS IT PRESIDENT OBAMA HIMSELF?
THE PUBLIC DESERVES ANSWERS.
>> Sean: SENATOR, LET ME PICK
YOUR LEGAL MIND FOR JUST A
SECOND.
YOU'RE THE NATIONAL DANTE DEBATE
CHAMPION, AND WE'VE WATCHED YOU
DEBATE.
>> YOU CAN TELL I WAS ONE OF THE
COOL KIDS IN COLLEGE.
>> Sean: OBVIOUSLY.
I WAS NOT PART OF THE CLUB.
ON A SERIOUS NOTE, WHERE YOU
CONVINCED THE ESPIONAGE ACT WAS
VIOLATED BY HILLARY, THE INTENT
OF DESTROYING THE EMAILS WAS TO
COVER UP AN UNDERLYING CRIME AND
ELIMINATE THE EVIDENCE?
ARE YOU CONVINCED THE FISA
COURTS, THAT A FRAUD WAS
COMMITTED BY OMISSION AND USING
THE FAKE, PHONY DOSSIER, THE
RUSSIAN DOSSIER?
AND ARE YOU CONVINCED THEY TRIED
TO UNSEAT A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION?
>> THERE'S SERIOUS UNDERLYING
EVIDENCE THOSE ISSUES YOU LAID
OUT.
WHEN IT COMES TO HILLARY
CLINTON, HER USE OF EMAILS, HER
VIOLATION OF THE LAWS CONCERNING
KEEPING CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
CLASSIFIED, THERE APPEARS TO
BE -- EVEN JAMES COMEY HAS
POLITICAL
POLITICIL
POLITICIZED WAS HE WAS, CALLED
IT GROSS NEGLIGENCE, BUT THERE
WAS AN EFFORT TO DESTROY
EVIDENCE, SMASH PHONES WITH
HAMMERS, USING BLEACH BIT AS YOU
MENTIONED TO ERASE HARD DRIVES.
WE NEED TO HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE NEED ACCOUNTABILITY FOR EACH
AND EVERY PERSON WHO VIOLATED
THE LAW, LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD
BE NONPARTISAN.
IT SHOULDN'T BE A POLITICAL
WEAPON USED AGAINST THOSE WHO
HAPPEN TO BE ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> Sean: I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR, THE WEAPONIZING OF OUR
INTELLIGENCE, THE ABUSE OF
POWER, THIS WAS NOT THE 99.9%
FBI.